sofern wir befinden uns hier auf der
mittelstraße in köln und hinter mir geht
es zum oscars und das oscars ist ein
gutes restaurant ist es auch justins
lieblingsrestaurant erwartet schon drin
auf uns wir gehen jetzt
sagen wir sind hier wir sind hier in
oscars was hier der vorteil ist man kann
nicht nur essen sondern auch direkt
shops ist sehr praktisch dass auch für
dich
mit einem kollegen kombinieren kann der
is nice feature aber was attraktiv
machen wir es tatsächlich das erste
frage wichtigste frage bei nbc hast du
es das lieblingsrestaurant oder hast du
auch so situationsbezogen verschiedene
das ist auf jeden fall situationsbezogen
mal hier muss man ehrlich sein es ist
immer so ein bisschen
gehobene gesellschaft und da sehe ich
mich eigentlich
sehe ich mich eigentlich eher nicht drin
weil ich mag es nicht wenn die leute
einen sauberen chancen also gar kein
problem wenn ich jetzt so jan komme
aber sonst sind hier gegen abend eher
leute die dann so auch mal schicker hier
sind und so ein bisschen komisch
angeguckt aber ich bin schon sagen das
ist einzig dass daraus aber ich kann
jetzt nicht auch ein fest festlegen aber
nicht jetzt zweite frage das ist eine
seite was hast du hier ein
lieblingsgericht ja ich es auch hier nur
ein gericht also nur das hindert
schnitzel mit den oscar freis und der
truppe mal
vielleicht mal irgendwann drittes video
wir auch wieder schmitz gemeinde
persönlich ja auch schon ziemlich oft
dass das hier sehr gut sein dass ich
noch nie gegessen ich glaube mir die
haben beim letzten mal da war das
schnitzel bisschen anders auch von der
consense ihr vielleicht haben dieses
rezept geschmeckt aber dennoch gut okay
dann heute sei der kritische ganz
bitterer weg sonst nehmen uns die ard
börse
da vorne können wir es nicht zeigen weil
wir deswegen finden ist eine riesige
leinwand adaptieren
er weiß aber auch schon direkt die
schicke karten hier sowie euro die rund
ja mit halb edge vom geklaut
sie haben gerade festgestellt dass der
schnitzel teurer ist als erwartet und
ich in erinnerung hatte deswegen müssen
sie den trainer oder abbrechen
wer heute schon ist es schon habe ich
schon 129 50 aber das gute ist
man hier nicht dafür da muss ich mich
gern man sich jetzt sowohl rechtens hier
unterwegs bin dann bestellen jetzt
werden wir mal das wiener schnitzel mit
den houska preis und der trifft ich
würde noch eine cola nehmen bzw da ist
die zitrone und zweitens was wirklich
eine besonderheit ist besitzt ja so halb
im fein stimmt ja also das ist überdacht
damit nicht nass ja aber kommt trotzdem
lüftchen das zum sommer ganz heiß und im
winter mir das heißt man wird hier auch
also wenn wir so rein kommen nachdem
drunter sitzen medium
und dann kann es richtig ein rein kurzen
stimmt du bist raus das heißt mehr
raucher ist hier kann sich den auch
reingehen also da gehören wir beide
jetzt nicht zu aber vielleicht ist es
leichter weil man hier so eine pfeife
neben dem tisch das wäre natürlich ein
angst vieler wenn diese ab 20 uhr noch
weiter anheben würden und
rufen mehr an
bord mit das werk sei es so hin wie
kathrin sicks oscars aber dürfen dieses
theoretisch verbieten weil ich hier auch
ein fehler und zigarre das ist oft
unangenehmer geruch sich gerade jetzt
eigentlich weniger die war auch diese
tiefer ich glaube 21
er hat ja auch so diese süße meinten
dass sein weil ich auch nicht ob man es
feiert aber können wir gut vorstellen
wenn du jetzt hier als stammgast schon
gemerkt hat begrüßen und du bist ja auch
jemand dem man hier kenne kann ich mir
vorstellen dass du sagen
also
also wir haben auf jeden fall ich hoffe
es ist so pankow mäßig trainiert also
eine etwas bruch costa vom schnitt her
darauf achtet
dass hier trifft mario prüfen meint
damit die oscar-preisträger sehen auch
nach außen also durch dieses kleine
schaufel sowie und die mayo wohl auch
sehr rein gehen dass das so kommt fast
anders vermuten ganz wichtig auch
die kleinen mit einer schneefräse
rohstoff glaubte aber verbaut haben grad
wieder schmerzt und jungen dann auf nun
254 nicht wenn man genau das macht alles
wieder wie aber muss schon sagen man
merkt auf jeden fall hier wird auch sehr
viel wert auf qualität gesetzt für den
geschmack das denn jetzt herausfinden
ja bitte danke sein service markt war
ich bin jetzt wirklich sehr gespannt
werden dann auch im vergleich zum
beispiel wärs ja ich kenne das ja schon
reichen während ich ja aber nicht viel
also erstmal damit nur den schnitzel
gespannt
er hat schon sehr gepflegt gefährlicher
mir aber wohl sagen das ist jetzt gerade
den kontrast aus natürlich sehr schön
knusprig und innen drin wer weiß
eigentlich heute von ihrer besten seite
muss man nicht bloß mit dem trüffel
da kann es auch ordentlich rein langen
bist du so der feine der das dann auch
mit der gabel ist im kommen in der pause
können das thema abzuwechseln gabel
weggabe sehr gefährlich
sein freund war wir haben jetzt der auch
in zukunft immer vorab bescheid geben
aber das so offen wie möglich nichts
strecke also wenn das sind 10 von 10 ist
es sonst immer eine 9,8 also das ist
jetzt nicht so schlecht mit kamera oder
so also wirklich ich bekomme jetzt
nichts dafür also
ich gehe gerne in st deswegen hab ich
mir das ausgesucht was ich mich gefragt
habe ja schon die figuren autos wie auch
einmal muss essen oder darf es und bin
ich auch luxuriös sein oder bist du eher
so der einfacher ist also ich will
hauptsache es schmeckt ich bin jetzt
nicht so dieser entität essen fügt dass
ich jetzt in den läden gehen muss und
nur so eben schon gesagt wir dieses
wohnzimmer feeling so ich jetzt gerne
neben einfach normalen leuten wo jetzt
nicht so auf so auf einen herab geguckt
wird oder selbst wenn die wissen dass
man vielleicht auch bisschen besser
verdient aber so mag das
innenministerium wenn man einfach so
haben will normal zu sorgen kann aber
ich gehe hier wirklich nicht wegen der
atmosphäre die bei dem schönen weil das
einfach lecker ist wenn du irgendwo ein
bisschen da ist nur wo dann geht man
halt auch mal ein ja aber auch nur weil
man das hier nicht hat und gerne mal
test wir haben auch schon gemeinsam
überlegen im setzkasten gemeinde wir
hatten überlegt dass wir die kurve auch
da machen was wir aber auch den
setzkasten gesprochen haben und da hat
der chefkoch höchst persönlich
versichert dass der mir wenn ich das
nächste mal einkommen begrüßte mache ich
auch setzkasten atemnot oder
schmecken erst mal müssen
wir mal aufgegessen ist natürlich sehr
sehr nah ist der weg bisher oder ist es
einfach nur das hitze für dich
eigentlich nur das schnitzel ich bin mir
generell nicht so der vorspeise und
bisher unerreichter auch nicht so krass
wie die organe aber so das ist eine
geile portion und wir werden das ganze
vielleicht noch bewerten also wir haben
uns überlegt verschiedene kategorien die
werde ich auch durchziehen gemeinsam mit
anderen gästen und dann vielleicht einen
kleinen vergleich machen so wie mein
bruder hat sein auto format aber du hast
noch eine gelegt
was ist ein was ist die nächste große
sache ich falls die rechnung machen ich
habe nichts großes was ansteht sieht
sich hier als werbeplatz haben wir keine
großen sachen sagen die letzte ich bin
erstmal froh dass ich für das jahr durch
bin mit allem nicht weil das ja wirklich
es ein paar turbulent aber es macht sehr
viel spaß das zu machen was man mag halt
gern der kreide war krass wir hatten den
papa release das einfach ausverkauft
weniger als 24 stunden vor weniger als
zwölf stunden oder das krankheit sich
auch nicht mitgerechnet sie ehrlich
sagen ja und das hat mich sehr gefreut
ich mir jetzt einfach erleichtert so
dass man jetzt entspannt in die
feiertage gegen brief mir jetzt zu
bewerten okay es gibt vier verschiedene
kategorien wie ich jetzt nicht ablesen
service essen am die enterprise erster
punkt service was heute über super
service verbot aber ist jetzt nicht
besonders positiv ausgefallen so
erwarteten service
zurückhaltend ich zurückhaltend
freundlich ohne irgendwie viel therapie
sage ich jetzt mal so einfach angenehm
also ich würde eine 5 von 5 gehen weil
es nichts zu meckern gibt aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass leute noch
mehr wert darauflegen beraten zu werden
aber wir wussten ja auch was wir neben
eigentlich ja das ding ist ich sags ja
mal wirklich angesprochen deshalb gehe
ich eigentlich unsere köpfe haben wir
viel innerhalb von viereinhalb einem
einmal habe ich auch sein tiroler
bestellen wollte schon länger gucken
müssen bis ins meiner gesehen gehört so
eigentlich immer aber das ist ja eine
ganze nacht lang 32
dessen kann man nicht sagen
also das war wirklich nichts was man
besser machen
köln sei kann man hier wirklich nach
ohne dass ich hätte irgendwie werblich
ist tiefer schnitt ambiente ich finde
wirklich am band ist wirklich ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal so es gibt nichts
vergleichbares wahrscheinlich im umkreis
von 200 kilometern ja das ist krass
finde ich persönlich einen ambiente ich
eigentlich auch eher ab und halten
dadurch dass hier auch ab und zu mal ein
bisschen zigarren auch beim essen die
nase kommt von neben zwischen kann man
das in zwei ambiente zellen und eine
viereinhalb okay dann wäre
wahrscheinlich schwächste punkt preis
als große stütze um die 20 würde ich
sagen aber also ein widerstand
ich würde
mich wirklich da komme das ist jetzt
nicht 55 würde ich sagen war für das was
ich bekommen habe ist es ja auch so
bezahlt hat schon eine stange geld für
was krasses hat aber auch nachteile mit
sich dann würde ich sagen seht ihr jetzt
die gesamtbewertung eingeblendet klassen
ich danke dir dass wir das gezeigt hat
wir sehen uns bestand bei wiederum
gemacht sein schnitzel zu essen und
[Musik]